ladies and gentlemen it is Tim Dylan
there welcome to the Tim Dylan show
Christmas episode we're very very
excited we're bringing you a special
treat we're taking famous 20 minute rant
from the patron archives called my last
Christmas which is about why I decided
to retire from spending the holidays
with my family only partially retire I
do go back occasionally for holidays but
it's really just kind of this kind of
epic rant that a lot of people connected
with about really trying to get rid of
your family and friends and trying to
level up that's what the holidays to me
are about thinking about what you have
in your life and what you can get rid of
who you can get rid of how fast you can
do it and how quickly you can leave
those people in the dust and ascend to
higher levels that's what I believe the
holidays are about they're about taking
stock of where you are and who you are
and trying to change both of those
things dramatically and immediately if
possible so I did this rant and it was
about a Christmas that I had and it was
a Christmas that shook me to the core it
made me realize that it was time to
enter a new phase of my life and a lot
of people have connected with it so we
hope you enjoy it if you don't enjoy it
it's probably because you're threatened
by it
because you know I'm right or maybe you
are one of these people that I don't
understand the thinks the holidays are
about togetherness and just making do
with what you have a lot of people feel
that way they're like the holidays are
just about being grateful and thankful
for what you have shut the [ __ ] up
that's not what they're about they're
about saying I want more okay enough
stop lying to yourself another stop
denying yourself you're an animal you're
on earth you're an animal now obviously
there's maybe some divinity you have the
ability to reason you know maybe there
is a God maybe you can I'm not saying
you have to stay an animal but you have
you know you have instincts you know
there's a
nature to you you want things it's
nothing wrong with that stop denying
yourself the pleasures of getting rid of
people the holidays are just about
looking around and saying thanks thank
you for this shitty job and this even
shittier family no they're not the
holidays are about driving by a big
beautiful house with a big beautiful
wreath on the door and a big beautiful
Christmas tree and looking at that house
and going I want that I want that I want
that warmth that security and that
safety and I deserve it and you know
what a lot of the people in my life
right now aren't helping me get that so
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
pretend I don't know them because our
friendships based on mutually assured
destruction that we both destroy each
other and my family is just based on
we're just a bunch of people don't know
we don't know what the hell we're doing
anymore world just staring at each other
some of that's nice the majority of it
isn't and we know that we're eating
garbage food and sweatpants were phoning
it in we're throwing a lot of good money
after bad so that's what the holidays
have always symbolized to me and I know
people have all kinds of different views
about it and I don't hold that against
anyone but the reality is the holidays
are about it's a quarterly review for
your life it's the end of the fiscal
year or the quarter whatever you say to
yourself listen let me figure it out let
me figure it out and that's what the
holidays are about looking around to
people going who's a central who's not
so that's the first part of the episode
second part of the episode we talk to
the great Sal Vulcano is one of the
Impractical Jokers it is the most
successful you know whatever you want to
call it prank show which they're not
really fans of that name they don't like
reality show either you know it has
elements of a game show but it is a
hybrid it's a few different genres it's
one of the most successful shows in the
last decade
it's a worldwide phenomenon those guys
sell out arenas all over the world and
and and they all experience success and
they're late in their mid-30s very
interesting story about how they came
together how long they all work day jobs
how long before they started making
money and then just you know the show
growing into the [ __ ] powerhouse that
it is today
where it's a worldwide sensation and
everybody knows about it it sounds an
insanely famous person when I've gone
out with them to dinner
people always recognize him it's really
insane especially in New York City but
pretty much I'm sure wherever he goes
there are people out there so it's very
interesting talking to him about that so
that's really the episode today we have
those two things happening is this our
final episode of the year then no we
have one coming out on the one on the
30th I think because [ __ ] month sucks
yeah you can't as my father said can't
get ahead can't get ahead they're always
trying to get you go get you can't get
ahead I've spent a lot of time we
released a Boomer Christmas video that's
funny I spent a lot of time with the
boomers over the last week they're
they're great people and they're very
fascinating to me because what's great
about the boomers is I've talked to
different boomers from different tax
brackets all over the place different
locations the sense of injustice that
they all have about the things that
they've been denied I love just they're
just they're somehow old victims many of
them have inherited homes victims you
know because then you got to renovate
those homes what a project many of them
you know worked at one company for 40
years that's not gonna happen anymore to
anyone we know
and I'm not saying these people should
be derided but I'm just saying I love
the idea that it's like still like her
it's rough man it's rough it's been
rough
you have no idea rough it's gonna get so
it's really it's a really fun episode
and maybe you like it maybe you don't
subscribe to the Tim Dylan show rate
review leave a 5 star rating we do
appreciate that tell friends and family
Thanks to everyone who bought the shirt
send us photos of you in the shirt we'll
put it up unless you're completely
hideous we're kidding we'll put it up
even if you're hideous doesn't matter
unless you're like deformed feel like
Elephant Man well actually if you are
Elephant Man we will put it up like if
you are deformed we'll put it up if
you're just kind of regular ugly I don't
know that it helps me or you but if
you're really good-looking or deformed
I'd like one of the extremes I don't
need you to just be like Plain Jane you
know but you know let me know let me
know how you feel folks send me the send
me the photos also live dates a lot of
them coming up Tim de la comédie dot-com
all over the place we're going to Austin
Texas in January we're going to Magoo
B's January in Baltimore Maryland we're
going up to Toronto coming back to
Caroline's in New York City in March
headlining those rooms so please check
out Tim Dillon comedy calm all the links
for tickets are on the website enjoy the
episode we'll be back we got another
episode coming on patreon with Luke
radowski the guy who stormed Epstein's
island in the Virgin Islands he's gonna
come on the show also we have patreon is
coming up with always the great ray Kump
and you know folks will have more shirts
working on a mega McCain shirt that
could be epic but it's got to be done
the right way it's got to be done the
right way I know somebody that knows her
they were with her the other night she's
not a fan of me understandable and we're
working on that we are working on
that'd be great to do Rogen with her me
as her her as her Joe as Joe fun times
when does this come out though tonight
Merry Christmas everybody
Happy New Year happy Kwanzaa Happy
Hanukkah happy winter solstice happy
[ __ ] holiday whatever the saternus
are Sam Tripoli will know what holiday
[ __ ] celebrate happy holidays
somebody on little st. James is singing
like in that Robert Goulet voice [ __ ]
wild [ __ ] world we live in man
it's truly unhinged
to an alarming degree really is not much
can be done this is not the boomers
become the boomers by the way I'm gonna
become the same thing people are gonna
come to mean you know 20 years if I'm
still around and they'll be like hey
[ __ ] going on I'll be like can't get
ahead always trying to get you gonna be
like satanic pedophiles run the whole
government I never like not good got to
make time to golf
hit hit the ball a little bit play 9
take some time they give you the card
you outraged be like buddy
we were outraged years ago we were
outraged decades ago but then we decided
that there's not really much left to do
except eat meatballs and wait for death
gotta take a moment for yourself you
know I'll you know what I'll be going to
see whatever act is like an old active
at that time I think I'm gonna see Liz
oh she's on her comeback tour you know
she lost her foot diabetes but she's
back she's playing the hits so that's it
folks that's what's gonna happen boomers
we're in porn boomers they became them
and I understand I it's you know all
these politically active people that are
on the ride in the laughs our ride far
laugh they're gonna realize it the
system's just gonna crush them like
everybody else don't call it a black
pill you stupid Fox
there's no blood pooling it's not a
black pill it's the pill it's the only
pill go get a [ __ ] life go get
married have kids do whatever you want
to do don't cocoon yourself on Twitter
with another with with a bunch of losers
it's not gonna work
the revolutions not coming shut up go
find something to [ __ ] do I'm not
saying don't be you know concerned don't
care but care about real people in real
life [ __ ] jump on the hashtags shut
up
get a life how about 2020 you get a
[ __ ] life stop talking about
Elizabeth Warren and Donald Trump they
don't care about you doesn't matter to
them you're a statistic on a sheet you
could take care of yourself you get
you'd be eaten alive it's the truth
you don't want to think like that you
think your tweets gonna save you you
think one of these shows he'll pass you
spends their time eating children he's
gonna turn around and like yeah you know
like you you think you're gonna send
them a letter about your papa don't work
at the factory and they're gonna be grow
up grown up go to Washington DC walk
around it's all demons from hell
it's all it is all the people that write
about politics talk about politics
they're soul these are kids you've never
been invited to parties they've never
had any fun they've never laughed they
Jay they're like drones they've had
their souls replaced by teleprompters
[ __ ] listicles these peoples
throughout you look in their eyes
there's nothing there
they're just go on MSNBC or Fox and they
spout inane nonsense
and you people oh oh look what does one
sad look what that one sir no no get a
[ __ ] go be somebody go start a [ __ ]
drug business become a crisis actor go
fake terrorist attacks go do something
real you know we will be I'll be putting
out on the patreon an article about the
Boston Marathon bombing if you want to
talk to your family over the weekend
about something Merry Christmas
why can't we hear from doe cars are not
yeah Happy Holidays
why does Dzhokhar tsarnaev not able to
give an interview is it because the FBI
used him and his brother is informants
and then said they didn't know who they
were and that they probably were not
sophisticated enough to make that bomb
maybe the FBI allowed them to have a
bomb so that they could catch other
people with bombs and then that bomb
went off and then they decided to lie
and say that they didn't know who they
were and then they got caught in a boat
one of them was shot they were clearly
trying to shoot both of them and then
they also killed a cop on MIT for no
reason they didn't even really try to
get away they just drove around in
Boston happy holiday
you know what you can do where you get
down
that's my new attitude in 2020 that
voice I'm gonna I mean comic comedy now
has been invaded by wealthy white woman
all every night you just performed the
ugg boots of boots and 300 and $400
sweaters that just stare at you they
want you to talk about dating and
avocado toast that's what they want to
talk about they're all just Chardonnay
Chardonnay and ugg boots to misery
nanahara
life's an unending merciless hell enjoy
the holidays folks if you have a turkey
let me say this before I leave if you
have a turkey again on Christmas you're
a [ __ ] psychopath
you should have turkey on Thanksgiving
and the Christmas you have a meat you've
Chateaubriand filet mignon of steak you
know you have maybe a ham the pasta
Seven Fishes you know pasta like a
lasagna whatever you don't have Turkey
again if you have Turkey again it's your
from a sick place with sick people and
you need to get away from them ASAP if
you're going to someone's holiday for
the first time and they're having Turkey
get the [ __ ] away from them get away
from them I wish if I could do it all
over again I'd be heterosexual I'd be a
banker I would date one of these [ __ ]
out boots that I have to make laughs and
we would go to ugg boots house and we'd
we'd meet mother ugh
mother ugh would be drinking maybe a
little brandy and she'd go hello hi
Colton my name would be Colton and I
thought I have a Patagonia jacket and
leather boots and I'd say whoo moon is
cool I went to Princeton and she's dying
Alton my name is Felicity and this is my
husband Benson hello
Colton I'm Benson no I went hunting
earlier this year or we'd be in secret
societies and we wear hoods and we'd go
in the middle of a field I don't know
what they do they probably do like a big
dance number where they're like Satan is
great
Satan is great Satan is great but
whatever okay but I'm not in a [ __ ]
green room of a comedy club I got to
entertain a bunch of ugg boots would
Tina Turner have been good if she didn't
get smacked in the face yes or no these
are questions for the the holiday
Christmas or would she have phoned it in
how do you how do you get what's love
got to do with it you get that if you're
happy now stop wanting your entertainers
to be happy there's a lot of
entertainers that are happy and healthy
and that's where everything is dog [ __ ]
it is dog [ __ ]
and you like it because entertainment
now it's just something that you know
happened you dumb [ __ ] oh he's talking
about uber I take ubers entertainment
that's not it that ain't it the highest
sacrament now is being relatable how
disgusting his dad that you have to go
into their world they don't want to come
into your world you have to go into
their world and they're [ __ ] dumb
world they're dumb world whatever these
retards are talking about
oh just disgusting I got to go now and
perform for the sorority that's here
[ __ ] Fairfield Connecticut snow
bunnies I'm gonna have to get up there
and tell them the truth tell them that
the country is run by a cabal of demons
that's what I'm gonna tell them and I
will also do jokes about the death of
the diner
declining quality of Wendy's and other
important things that while they night
might not be as important or certainly
important certainly not gonna skip over
them thank you could you let me know
what I have to go right I love you
thanks we're firing everyone after
tonight I'm gonna fire everyone and
every comedy club I work I bring them
and I go we appreciate it but tonight's
gonna be it tonight's gonna be it for
you thanks for coming tonight's gonna be
it we've enjoyed it we hope you've
enjoyed it you don't have to go home but
you can't stay here that's how I'd
firefighter business had fire everyone
like that ago hey you don't have to go
home but you can't stay here and they go
what do you mean I go you're out that's
what I mean my heart goes out to
everybody who's working on Christmas
like myself by the way I'm [ __ ]
working too so don't give me nothing I
got seven shows on New Year's Eve
so the reality of this situation folks
is this some God you see mailed me hey
how's next Monday morning or Tuesday
morning or even Sunday for what's this
guy mentally ill oh this is this so I
like this guy this is our future
I like James Altucher yeah some kid
asked me to do the show in Highland Park
no no no no more no more I'm gonna start
diving into the audience at these
hipster shows and biting people in the
face and we'll see how many shows I get
asked to do hey was Tim Dylan funny the
other night you know he was doing okay
but then he just bit someone's face the
cops had to come so we're not gonna
invite him anymore
yeah leave me alone hey if you don't own
a club don't message me unless you're in
skullenbones you [ __ ] you can get me
in these retards call me they look I'm
in the Penn State's combos
hey shut the [ __ ] up yeah I'm in the
National Community College combo shut up
please
you [ __ ] d-list [ __ ] scabs I can't
get a goddamn real
I got these [ __ ] tertiary people
third and fourth tee and nobody's
messaging me I'm trying to get in a real
elite a Rothschild something like that
getting these [ __ ] nobodies he's
[ __ ] the fourth or fifth guy that
rounds out the [ __ ] golf trip that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about he's messaging
me tell me know what's really like not
even that cool yeah I know it isn't I'm
talking to you
God stand-up comedy sucks it really is
the worst art form I mean it's the best
but it sucks so much who's that guy fire
him fire him he's fired who's that he's
getting from firing him character that
guy's everybody's gonna get fired by the
way it's called I walk around fire
everybody hello sir how are you
what's your name again Tim Dylan nice to
meet you have a good holiday are you
excited about the holiday you excited
about the holiday [ __ ] yeah you're
you're Puerto Rican you do not look
Porter ticket a white guy just walked in
I was like I'm cooking Porto Rican like
what does that mean you're cooking out
Puerto Rican it's interesting well have
a good holiday sir we'll wrap this up
folks cuz frankly I'm not paid enough to
do what I do I give you everything for
free and you take a [ __ ] in my throat
okay every other podcast you've got nine
houses I'm struggling to feed that fat
cat in LA okay I should have made my
podcast avocado toast in your [ __ ] and
then I'd have 75 million people
listening to it and I talk about my dry
snatch like everybody else cuz that's
what everybody wants they want to hear
about you dry snatch and how [ __ ] up
you got in college and at your friend's
wedding okay we're not doing that okay
we're telling you the truth
and that's hard to [ __ ] monetize so if
I could do it all over again I'd be a
single loudmouth Jewess with a dry
snatch hi I'm Timmy the trash can
and I love trash popcorn boxes and candy
wrappers hmm
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons
Christmas week is now this is the week
between Christmas and New Year's when
you were a little kid this was the best
week of the year because you could play
with all the toys you got at Christmas
and you were off from school and all of
your friends were off from school and it
made it the best week of the year when
you're an adult this week is harrowing
it's horrible it's it's like it's like a
hangover for an entire week you don't
know what time it is you don't know what
day it is you're not really you're not
at work
nothing's going on but you're not also
not at work somehow you're like involved
you know work is coming it's a nightmare
week it doesn't ever feel like it should
be daylight out you walk outside it's
like if you were ever if you went to I
was at parties in high school not to
brag I went to a few parties in every
now and then I used to love drugs and
alcohol so I would wake up the next day
at the party house which by the way bad
move and a real almond of things to come
if you're waking up at the party house
it means you have a problem but what I
saw is what you should never see which
is the house the day after the party it
has that dank feel it smells bad it's
just ashtrays overflowing with cigarette
butts stains from your hope booze and
you're looking around the house and
there's just Sun peering in illuminating
the filth which seems so fun only a few
hours before it seemed okay the family
that embraced this that lived like this
that open their home and allowed you to
[ __ ] you thought these are good people
they let us come in here do drugs
alcohol with them with their children
they let us trash the small piece of
real estate they happen to own they let
us depress the value of it for several
hours and then we all leave we don't
give a [ __ ] and if you still leave at 3
a.m. in the dark and you wake up in your
house or somebody else's house you're
fine and that magic still stays with you
and that's an important magic to retain
for as long as possible but when you
wake up the next day at the party house
and you see it in the day and you see
the family in the day these people these
vampires that are but sunlight they
scatter around like roaches you save
yourself this is not good this is what
the week between Christmas and New
Year's feels like to a person you feel
like you are seeing something you
shouldn't see you feel like it should go
Christmas and then you have like an hour
or two and then New Year's party and
then let's go it's a new year we're in
this weird vortex between the absolute
hell and the vapid conversation you have
to suffer through with your family oh my
god on it it doesn't feel like Christmas
this year I don't you know the you know
and I went to my party and this is the
end of and I've been pretty open about
this this is my final year spending the
holidays with my family and I will
because I want to be successful and I've
realized that success requires to
constantly keep climbing and when I look
around these parties these holiday
parties I'm at them like this very
little room to move up in this structure
you know there's nowhere to really go
we've done it and I'm thankful and
they're good people these people but
next year I think I'll go to an island
or I'll get away somewhere and I'll or
maybe I'll go spend it with friends I
was invited to spend it with friends
this year and I said now I'm gonna go
and I'm gonna spend it with my family
and it was nice because it was only nice
because I I felt like it was a kind of
the closing of a chapter
and here's my thing and I'll throw this
out there to the phoning and in of the
holidays across the board has got to
stop and this is happening and what the
older generations are now dead or
they're dying they're bedridden they
can't do anything anymore they're old
they're there they're sitting in a chair
we love them we thank them but they're
not they're not the captain of the ship
my grandmother has died my nanny is left
but she's not really doing anything
anymore
so the responsibility for the holidays
falls on the baby boomers a selfish
generation of people who have sucked
everything out of this country and given
it nothing
demonic drug addicts who were drunk on
cheap credit for their entire lives
mortgage their future mortgaged our
future disgusting selfish hedonistic
people without honor without valor
without intelligence and I and I say
this with all due respect many of them
are fans but that generation largely not
all of them but a lot of them
it's phoning in time and you know like
one of them said to me and I'm not gonna
say who but because this is you know
this is my family but it's also there's
other people's families involved and I
just observed holidays on Facebook and
Twitter people paper plates plastic cups
is it a GoFundMe I thought that was a
GoFundMe I thought I was gonna take out
a credit card and donate to you why are
you advertising your inability to own
glassware I mean this is really
something that I I've seen I've seen
these holiday look at photos I'm not
making this up look at photos of
holidays from the 50s from the 60s from
the seventies from the eighties look at
photos of holidays now everybody's
dressed like a bum people are sitting in
the basement of Red Solo cups it's like
you're playing a beer pong in the
basement like a [ __ ] child
people go to supermarkets to cater the
meal supermarkets where the staff is on
heroin okay I went with my father he
goes we're picking up some food we're
having catered not from a caterer not
from a restaurant from the super-mo we
went to the supermarket and got the food
can you imagine this is the day Christ
was born come to our house and you could
eat supermarket food in the den this is
ridiculous well I have a holiday
somebody said to me they're like nobody
cares where the food comes from yes they
do I do I do I don't get it I also don't
get the this potluck dessert will you
just give up and you go all host but I
need everybody else to bring dessert
because I can't manage to buy a dessert
or make a dessert even though I'm
hosting the party and it is my
responsibility to ensure that people
have a good time I'm gonna just let
whatever dirtbags I have coming over
stop at some local [ __ ] 7-eleven and
buy a [ __ ] cheesecake and have them
bring it over I'm gonna let my my aunt
make a chocolate pudding pot it looks
like a child made it where the crust is
uneven and the mousse is overflowing and
it's looked like a jello no bake
remember those remember when jello came
out and said to fat people
you shouldn't go near an oven you're fat
but what about if we gave you something
you could just stir put in the
refrigerator for a half hour and then
eat like a pig
on your couch while you watch The Drew
Carey Show and it sold well so well but
that's what that's what we're eating
we're eating pudding pie there was a
dessert I swear to Christ called dirt
there's a dessert called dirt these are
adults these were adults it was a bowl
and they told you how they made it they
weren't embarrassed they told you how
they made it
whip cream pudding cream cheese it's
just this glop
that looks like human [ __ ] and then they
take cookies and crumble the cookies up
and put them on the top and then they
put gummy worms in it so that it looks
like the dirt how about bringing actual
dirt could it have been more insulting
if you had brought actual dirt with real
worms I mean this is disgusting and
people eat it like it's okay not okay if
you host you do the dessert you don't
trust people to bring [ __ ] to your home
you know what they're gonna do they're
gonna do it on the [ __ ] cheap cuz
they're just gonna [ __ ] nobody knows
who brought what that's what it is if
you do a potluck dessert you still have
to stand in a circle and go what did you
bring and you should be judged [ __ ]
harshly but nobody does that they throw
it on the table and they run away to the
other room they don't give a [ __ ] that
nobody's eating the garbage fire of a
[ __ ] dessert because they're gone
so again when I was growing up we had a
New Year's Day party and the New Year's
Day party we had great food but the
dessert was Peach Melba one dessert that
was it now I know people now they're
like well you know some people chocolate
people some people aren't some people
want cheesecake you know what folks were
trying to please everyone and we're
pleasing no one that's what we're doing
we're trying to include everyone and
we're including no one ok so it bothers
me again I just felt a lot of the food
where I was was was phoned in phoned in
and I don't like that because I remember
when I was growing up my grandmother and
and my nanny and he ends the man as well
everybody would help they would really
get into it they would cook for days and
it was a mark of pride it was a mark of
pride of great the food was everyone
looked forward to it all [ __ ] year now
these people go to a supermarket and buy
something they buy macaroni and cheese
that somebody stirred in an oxycontin
frenzy in Long Island I what are we
doing why
are you inviting me to your home I'm
insulted I don't know how you're not
insulted I mean I try not to yell but it
gets angry and I know that everyone says
y'all read it everyone's like you're
loud and sad and that's very instructive
I had no idea I appreciate that I
appreciate your candor these guys will
hopefully fix the levels very tough for
me I know I'll kill tell me everyone was
like you're loud you're loud on it
because I'm playing to a room of people
it's 300 people and when I get worked up
I get worked up and you know it's not my
fault you should be watching kiloton I
don't know who listens to kill to kill
Tony's a visual experience you're
watching on the live Jimmy watch to
YouTube but I am trying I'm working on
that I'm working on not being his lap
but I get angry I get angry because
there's real issues there are real
problems
I saw people's holidays and I just I sit
back and I judge on social media and I
think that listen I think that I
understand people that say you know what
we're gonna use paper and plastic and
you know what I'm not I'm not saying in
every instance that's not appropriate
okay what I'm saying is that the
formality of the holiday to me matters
and I think you should you should say to
yourself you know what we're gonna we're
gonna let everybody drink at a big-boy
cups and they're gonna eat on plates
like people we're not gonna give them
we're not gonna give them plastic knives
that break in the food and forts were
they the [ __ ] things fly off we're
gonna give them real utensils because
Christ was born today and whether you're
whatever you feel religiously the
significance of that event my stepmother
got everybody's slippers she does this
every year she gets a gift for the whole
group last year was Snuggies you know I
always try to talk about 9/11 when she
hands out the Snuggies to everybody
everyone's like it's so soft it's so
soft I said why why did building seven
fall
it wasn't even hit it's just fun I like
to have fun because you end up in these
conversations with people that are vapid
and meaningless people are talking about
why they why they decided to become a
teacher could anything we know what you
decided to become a teacher cuz you
don't like to work and you have nothing
to offer the world that's we get it we
get it why don't you become a teacher
you're not a fan of hard work and you
don't have anything to offer that's what
that's the only thing anyone should ever
say why they became a teacher became a
teacher like it's a [ __ ] like you won
the Heisman you're gonna go through each
story start talking about how you did it
why do what was your origin story tell
us tell us
ah you went to college and you realize
you wanted to have the two best months
of the year off well you did nothing and
he wanted to be done with your job every
day by 2:30 ha ha okay listen my
grandmother was a teacher I know a lot
of teachers get mad at me because I talk
a lot of [ __ ] about them like I just did
but the reality of the situation is just
I never [ __ ] on teachers until they
started saying that the most important
job in the world would you you don't
it's not even in the top hundred jobs
that are important teaching you know
here's why everyone wants to do it
there's no shortage of people doing it
okay so if you decide to not go to work
tomorrow there's [ __ ] a trillion
people called subs that are there to
step in and can do your job immediately
maybe not as good as you but they can do
your job they can approximate your job
but this is what you got to do and
you're there in the holidays you're
gonna sit down and you're gonna tolerate
that you have to tolerate that as an
appropriate conversation someone in the
room telling you why they decided to be
a teacher and you have to sit there and
go yeah I started assigning that you
know how to cheat it you just wanted to
be a teacher oh that's good it's not
it's ridiculous so we get these slippers
and then she's like everyone put the
slippers on I don't want to slippers on
okay I want to tie a noose around my
neck but she didn't buy everyone a noose
that would be funny
you know what I got everyone this year a
noose funny she goes that would be great
gifts because 2019 is gonna be rough but
don't worry everyone I got us old nooses
that would have been too dark people
would got upset so we all put the
slippers on to take a photo with
everyone with the slippers on okay to
commemorate this and then one of my
aunts starts like well standing a circle
to dump slippers one of my aunt's like
through the hokey-pokey and everyone
starts doing the hokey-pokey and I'm
standing there and I want to kill myself
I literally want to end my own way I
want to grab something sharp and stab
myself and I want my blood to sputter
out while everyone's doing the hook
because I'm like this is [ __ ] crazy
that this is going on right now the
Hokey [ __ ] Pokey we're all adults
there's no children here there are no
kids this is an important distinction
there are no kick these are all adult
people they're doing the hokey-pokey and
it's like all right well you're not
really listening to this show if you're
doing the hokey-pokey
you'll probably don't want to hear that
George W Bush George HW Bush might have
had a hand in killing Kennedy or at
least knew who did you don't want to
hear about satanic pedophile cults and
you don't wanna hear about the Russian
mob you don't want to hear about the
deep state the underworld the overworld
I get it's fine it's fine with me you
don't want to hear about the Craigslist
sex stories you don't want to hear about
the morgue and dead hookers Raycom
finding things in the cavities of
people's bodies fine there's got to be a
happy medium between that and the
[ __ ] hokey-pokey I know my dad is a
musician my dad sits down he starts to
play guitar and here's the thing with my
dad I love my dad my dad is very
talented he's a great guitar player and
he hasn't done in a while and he can
still play guitar but the songs he's
writing are not good anymore he's
they're not good songs anymore because
he's out of practice okay and he's just
writing about the [ __ ] he does every day
he's a wine salesman he sells wine so
all of the [ __ ] songs are like a
the train today to sell a little wine I
go into the city and I go when I sell
red wine sometimes it's white wine and
I'm like you know you're really
describing your day with three cords of
music this is not they're just not deep
songs because he's he's checked out he's
at an age where he's got his wife he's
got his three dogs who he loves and
they're all named Maya's named after
Maya Angelou Ruth is named as Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and Fred is named after
Frederick Douglass swear to God I don't
know why they're so these politically
charged names or whatever but his wife's
big liberal and the kids a big liberal
the grand-prize a huge liberals so this
is their into this [ __ ] and he tells
people about the names the history of
the names of the dogs no one cares he
did it at my grandmother's funeral it
was wildly inappropriate people were
crying he's showing the pictures going
fred has named it for Frederick Douglass
it was like hey cool it rein it in rein
it in but he he start singing these
songs and he's like I take a newspaper
ride on the train with coffee that I
drink to sell the wine what I'm sitting
everybody's [ __ ] great he's like I
want to move down south cuz it's
summertime everywhere I'm like God
writing songs are so [ __ ] easy I was
sitting there going man if I did that
[ __ ] writing songs are so goddamn easy
and pointless in the summer it is hot
but in the winter it is not if you have
an acoustic guitar behind it people are
like oh yeah this is great
he's an artist he's gonna artist well
these other idiots in the room were like
this is deep this is deep [ __ ] this is
good and then my uncle's girlfriend's
son who's 47 I don't know how old she is
a hundred she looks great but her son I
figured your son's coming he's 47 I'm
like he oh he's elderly your elderly son
is coming so he walks in he's all
so a guitarist so he starts to play when
I swear to God he goes I spending time
with my friend and she has an 11 year
old son and me and me and the 11 year
old started to write a song together so
then he goes and plays the song that an
11 year old wrote I swear to God and
he's like and it's all based on the
colors
he's like rainbow shine blue what are
you gonna do green green green whatever
and yellow
you're so mellow and I'm like are you
[ __ ] that kid because that's a bad
song how are you how are you a 47 year
old man you're gonna play a song and 11
year old wrote and he's like he's like
children it's just so beautiful you know
where their minds go and I'm like what
children are idiots they're stupid and
their thoughts are worthless okay for
the most part okay I know sometimes like
a child's like they're they have that
childlike wonder and they're like
they're nice and they're like oh they're
like let's not you know they don't know
what genocide is yet and they're not on
you know they don't live stream from
some bunker and there's lots of benefits
to them but I don't wanna hear song
written by children it's stupid but my
father songs weren't all that much
better I'm on the train with coffee it's
the morning later on it'll be the
afternoon and so I'm watching these two
people seeing these will do respect
[ __ ] songs literally [ __ ] songs
blue what are you gonna do and we're all
in the den and they're playing these
guitars red what do you say when it's
red violet it's like what and and I just
I'm checking out I'm just really and I
said to myself I said this is great I'm
enjoying this it's lovely and I'm not
but I'm saying this is nice because this
is the end this is the final Christmas
the last Christmas I wish everyone well
and next Christmas I don't know what
I'll do I don't know where I'm going but
it is not there's no more sing-along
hokey-pokey [ __ ] going on we're done no
more supermarket pie no more so what
made you want to be
teacher I've never met a teacher before
is it the benefits and the exorbitant
amount of money is that it is it the
time you have off
is it the relatively short day is it the
commute from your home ah
is it the fact you get to boss people
around all the time that aren't of age
well you know if folks I don't want to
sound bitter they did get me uh they did
get me slippers I did get slap bars all
right we are here in the in the kitchen
of Sal Vulcano
we've just got me four slices of
cheesecake this is you know when you
have friends like this it's like you
know it's very easy to stay on the
straight and narrow and stay in a good
place food wise when you have people
like this in your life that really treat
you well this is it's the cheesecake is
the best cheesecake I think in New York
you know I'm so glad that you say that
because yeah I respect your opinion we
got to eat a bunch yeah we talk food a
bunch yeah I also just see you're
instagramming they're not I look to you
as an authority oh yeah and I and and I
see I share a love but you have way more
education on food than well my family's
in the business to an extent right I
mean my uncle is and we grew up around
really good restaurants and I really
it's the one other business that I would
consider getting into like I love comedy
I love being a comedian but if I
succeeded on the level of you you know
or you know in that orbit would it be
something I played around with the idea
of like opening a small rationally you
would yeah you know I was talking the
other night we went out to dinner is me
and Andrew Schultz and Yanis and Chris
and I'm like I'm coming to everybody in
five years for investors in a restaurant
they all loved because we all you know
we all like eating ingly but I'm
investing in one now for my childhood
friends yeah it's it's it's a thing like
I just observed the business for so long
and I have a great asset and my uncle a
great resource sure that I I feel like I
would you know listen everything's a
risk but I think with the amount of with
the right amount of money it would be a
that calculated rest I would like a
million dollars before I leave ah you
know I have a menu on my phone that I
will show you know but this cheesecake
is from Peppa Lee nose yeah which I
stumbled upon it's good I mean everybody
says juniors I like juniors SNS and the
Bronx is great blah blah blah but this
place is the lightest cheesecake on the
planet let's not get it I mean I've had
I've had plenty of amazing cheesecake
right some that have blown my balls off
right so but you know when I give this
cheesecake to you and you confirm I feel
it means the what because sometimes if
you can believe it
yeah I've given this cheesecake to
people who are like it's really good I
don't know if it's the best time well
well you know what it is my friend I
sent my friend and his girlfriend to don
Angie which is in the West arrestor on
the West Village
the other day one of the most
interesting Italian restaurants really
good food
you know phenomenal food and you know
they were basically like uh-uh it's okay
and it's like but you you don't know the
dip
what are you looking for you need a
simple dish yeah a simple dish right
people could look at a simple dish be
like oh it's just you know it's just
rigatoni with a little bit of red sauce
right I think no no you and you have to
understand something this
distinguishment between those things
yeah this is made perfectly it's really
it's it's the line from I think it was
you know I forget maybe who's the
birdcage where it was just like you know
most people are animals it's like if you
can't appreciate something don't pretend
like I don't know a lot about fashion I
know very little about fashion so I
don't walk around Madison Avenue and
tell people what's what right I don't
tell people what's is that jacket worth
10 grand maybe it is to me it's not
yours like I don't know
so if it's worth it to you and that's
how you want to spend your money go do
it
but I don't tell people their value
system is wrong you know sure cuz I
don't know about it I don't know what
lambskin leather is right I'm sure it's
great it sounds nice as fashion is a lot
like art where it is wholly subjective
and questionable yeah and its person a
person and there's no right or wrong
right food food your body tells you yes
is-is-is excellent lie yeah this is more
like sports because athleticism to me
about consistency like somebody that can
do something over and over again better
than everybody else
right to me that is 100% like what you
look for in a restaurant like they're
hitting the mark more often than not all
the time that doesn't mean every single
meal right what it means what maybe
every dish on the menu yeah that's why
I'll never write someplace well I'll
write a place off of everything's
terrible service in the food you could
tell right away oh [ __ ] this is yeah I
got myself in this [ __ ] here yeah but if
something like you know something
sometimes it's one dish that's why I
always yes a lot of times I'll ask the
waiter is there a dish on this menu that
you think is prepared in a more unique
way or a way that like that you think is
special and I need to try I'll always
defer to them hopefully they say what I
wanted yes if they don't it's a little
bit of a confidence it's a tug of war
I always ask a waiter I love when I
sometimes you go to a place and they're
very honest like Long Island for example
they are brutally honest and a lot of
the waitresses at diners and stuff are
holder and they just don't care anymore
about anything and you'll say is there
something here you like [ __ ] I don't
need anything you know they just have
that gritty voice of somebody she's like
I wouldn't need anything yeah you're
like okay well you know I think are you
a guy that grew up eating good stuff or
is it something he came to kind of later
on and not in I wouldn't say grew up in
any type of I didn't have a palate for
anything like that
no not at all just just homemade stuff
maybe yeah he's my grandma my grandma
cooked really well on my grandpa and my
my my stepmom cooks really well do you
got cook no yeah I don't right my lady
my lady's a great cook yeah Domino I had
Super Bowl party food that was yeah
beyond belief but I don't actually and I
lived alone for like a cool decade and I
was a guy that didn't complete basics or
I just bought my food now that the shell
is so big its massive now it's worldwide
you guys are on Stadium tours oriented
towards things like that do you ever
look back at think like what do you miss
the most you're just not able to do now
because I've gone out with you and it's
amazing to me I know how successful you
are
but it's so when you
I mean we've gone to Broadway shows
where the entire theater turns around
and looks at you when you walk in the
theater you know taffy and I like my
sign Pretender look at me - you'll wave
and I pose but you you are really just a
magnet for people and you say people
come up to you on the street don't you
start recording here blessing and a
curse
Rhino first of all when I on places like
it doesn't always happen but I live I I
the other guys are more open to it than
I especially Joe and James on the show
right which I envy right you know James
who actively welcomes it yeah I think
that that's probably better than what I
do it's not that I don't appreciate it
or welcome it or anything like that it's
just that I'm by nature a very much more
probably person I always have been right
I preferred not to be noticed yeah
and especially if I you know these days
that we're humans and we do you don't I
find I have to do a low hat no hood and
things I got a lot it helps a little bit
even if it deters 50 percent or whatever
right but you get to I had to constantly
remind myself I just [ __ ] relax
because yeah but you don't realize the
sauce is festering and I and I end up
getting social anxiety yeah because I I
feel like people were let me tell you
just from the other side it is much
worse to not have to disguise yourself
and not because that is in much more I
know several people in that position me
being one of them and it is is far
preferable to be like how do i I don't
sneak into this restaurant instead of
being like well I could just walk
through this restaurant naked and no one
will care it's just you know it is it is
just and I'm I never turn down a kid I'm
open to talking to anyone at any time
right
it's just said if I'm with if I'm on
like if I'm with my you know significant
other or with children or my grandma or
things like that yeah well in the middle
of chewing at a restaurant yeah just
certain times it's like each I wish this
wouldn't happen yeah other than open to
whatever and also especially when people
are very respectful yeah yeah most of
them you know a lot of times they'll
just turn on the camera which is just a
weird [ __ ] thing yeah
something is broke in somebody's mind
yeah if they don't know that not even
I'm [ __ ] basic-cable successful you
know I'm you know making my way in
comedy yeah I don't get me wrong I would
never change anything for the world and
I am more successful than I ever thought
I was I can't even imagine what reals
real celebrities and real successful
people right and real like who consider
real celebrities I mean the people that
are globally famous for a decade like
what would you say Tom Hanks yeah Smith
I don't know these people these people
beyond say oh yeah yeah these people
they will then again here's the thing
though they their success their wealth I
think matches their success in a way
that they can set up an infrastructure
to navigate something like it's hard to
be able to run up to Beyonce with an
iPhone it would say it is right what's
the weirdest phenomenon I learned is it
now it's a little different but when we
first got on TV people just equate
television with and any type of Fame
with complete wealth yeah right well I
was making other thing I make millions
of dollars I live in a box
I made a very modest if not low wage
from the first few years of course
so like I'm you know I'm the same as
having a decent regular job and everyone
just thinks you know and then and but
then that the show is getting popular to
a place where they play it so much that
everyone kind of knows me but then my my
I don't have the infrastructure to
shield myself from anything like that so
I'm just out there man how does this
idea of becoming a comedian happen in
your life like how does this start
wanted to be a comedian since I'm a
child oh wow I don't know why I how I
did some school stuff on stage got some
laughs I was a class clown but not like
disrespectful just [ __ ] the guy that
I made everyone laugh right and that was
like through grammar school in high
school at least I feel I don't know and
I just I always wanted to I just I
idolized Eddie Murphy and Bill Cosby as
a kid right
how do you link up with the Joker's
eventually do you start on your own and
then yes oh yeah sure so I started doing
improv at first yeah I was too nervous
to do stand-up actually like 20 years
ago maybe even more I did like stand-up
writing classes because I was so
desperate to to want to be one but I was
too nervous to get up and I didn't know
anyone and I didn't know how to get my
foot in the door so what is Writers
Workshop and I went and it was like a
stand-up comic teaching a class and he'd
give writing assignments and we come in
read them share them critique him come
back refine them and I think like it's
like eight weeks or 12 weeks earth was
you'd have a class show you know what's
funny there are people in that that we
took that class with you that bring it
up they're like I took that class which
sounds there's no way they remember you
don't think so no way in the world oh
hell I will tell you yeah I remember the
teacher and I remember no joke I
remember like at least my face if not
name almost don't hold like dozen people
in that class and only one person I
thought was really could have been a
comic everyone else was because it's a
mixture it's a course it's like I want
to be better at public speaking I want
to be better at parties it's like you
know [ __ ] you I'm trying right yeah but
it was oh me my friend still talked
about it
there was this old German couple okay I
could find their names because I kept
the class contact sheet it's like I'm a
hoarder and I keep [ __ ] like that I have
it to this day that's and we'd come in
and you know this is we were writing on
people call all of those people and tell
them how much more successful you are
than that you should just call them ago
hey we took a class 20 years ago at
Gotham I don't know if you remember the
here's what you guys been up to here's
what I want to do yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] I
know I have the shape you can because
recently the Staten Island Museum did an
exhibit on us from from high school to
now and it was there for like eight
months and I dug through all this stuff
to give them all these like they put him
in like the you know like oh here's the
right the email where we decided what
the name of the group and wrote a [ __ ]
and I found that so I know I have it
next time I do you're next on to your
podcast I'll bring it we'll go through
the list we will call them amazing I
would love that be it would be
fascinating so you take that writing
class were talking mm yeah 19 I was 98
90 I was in college coming out of
college and going to add a finance
degree I was gonna go work at Prudential
securities and I knew that that wasn't
really what I looked you start college
at 17 they're like what do you want to
do and I'm just like I have no clue what
whatever buddy knows well how do you
make money I'm like this was my literal
reasoning at 17 don't know what I want
to do no I want to make money finance
means money right so I'll do finance
didn't know any I didn't know what it
meant didn't know what I was doing right
pick tip graduated with that degree yeah
mind you hated it skirt skated through
college got good grades
cuz I I knew how to do school yeah but I
only retain things I was interested in I
have no knowledge of finance that came
out of the school I started working at
Prudential securities with a finance
degree and then I started going to these
classes I started going to acting
classes at HB studios just cuz I needed
to know that I was also doing that you
needed to have that that thing that
you're passionate about yeah you have
some role in your life no it's funny to
all we should do this okay yeah I also I
think I believe that we used to write
and what you said make photocopies of
the material back to Gotham yeah and
bring in if there's 12 kids in the class
you would write your stuff and photocopy
it and give out your work to the other
12 people so when you read it everyone
could read it out loud and critique so
we hand wrote so I believe to that I
saved other students material Wow
and the old German couple they would no
joke I think they were about 70 they
were like native New Yorkers write this
and they just were like a cute
fun-loving couple that was still kind of
in love I guess but they had thick
accents and they thought they were wave
they were pretty [ __ ] cool now
there's 17 going to a Gotham workshop
classroom together but they also had an
air of arrogance about them yeah and
they were beyond criticism in the class
which was fascinating right she thought
especially the woman the guy was like
was like very like sophomoric in an
endearing way none of the material I
mean this was hogwash material picture
just handing a pencil and paper to a
I'm saying right jars of course and she
I remember she came in and she was so
proud one day and she said I have like
this whole bit on dieting yeah and she
went to go and he's like all right why
don't you go ahead and I forgot her name
and she was okay and she like everyone
kept a stouter papers and she looks down
and she was brimming with anticipation
like smirking like wait till you hear
what I'm about to drop on you I remember
an old a 75 year old she's had it right
here and she looks up she goes and
people cannot see my face but you see
what I'm crying she was like wait you're
not ready for me right and then she said
dieting is not easy you you gain you
lose two pounds you eat a slice of
tomato you gain three and then she
leaned back and waited leave her just
like adorn me yeah with cheers yeah it
was amazing and then you know we were
like okay you know like yeah you know
you know okay you know can you expound
on it I read you the joy I've made the
Peretti joke that was that was the joke
yeah that she wrote that way yeah yeah
that's so crazy yeah but you know you
get a glimpse in a classroom like that
what's very interesting is you get a
glimpse into I think the delusion that
you need you need a little bit agree
wholeheartedly you need a little bit of
delusion to push you through especially
the beginning the beginning of comedy is
brutal and most people don't understand
how brutal because they haven't that's
like you are you're literally in the in
a pitch-black room and you don't know
what you're doing you don't know how you
don't know where to go what to say who
determine what's good what's not good
right there's something in your head you
think is good is by the way my stuff was
[ __ ] right I mean III remember I want I
just remember one of my topics I was
engaging in how like religious people
are hypocrites right I'm in behind you I
was raised Catholic I went to Catholic
school from from kindergarten to senior
of college right I'm not mean I'm not
religious but I was not not not not what
I say they would double agent my bit was
how they you're in church and you give
this peace be with you and then two
minutes later
they're all flipping each other off
cutting each other off in the parking
lot when they're leaving right and and
so on and so it wasn't good right at
least was just touching upon something
that I knew about or it wasn't you gain
do you lose two pounds you have a tomato
you gain three game three yeah that you
you weren't that's um that's my crop
like in the beginning most people I
think are you know when you tell anybody
that you're doing comedy you're gonna be
a comedian there are people that think
you're funny that are supportive but the
idea that you would make a living at it
or you'd make a career of it people are
just like okay buddy you know yeah nor
did I know if I would make a career
right I loved it
yeah my goal at that point yet wasn't
yet a career I was like cuz cuz you know
honestly a career feels pretty grand
right unless you're sacrificing
everything yes and you know that I'm on
a couch and I'm poor and I'm not doing
anything but this and that's your goal
but I didn't commit that far yet I had a
full-time job really that's what it's
about I think cuz we tell everybody in
our culture right now that you can be
whatever you want to be you can follow
your dreams these are all good and
positive things to tell people but we
don't tell anybody about the word
sacrifice we don't that is that is it
been eliminated and there's something
very dishonest sacrifice everything
every thought it's not something crap
it's sacrifice quality of life yes
sacrifice sleep and health yeah
sacrifice personal relationships correct
sacrifice dignity correct sacrifice just
not sleep back yeah I still have the rat
I still have I still have quality of
life dig I'm waiting for dignity back we
take it a year or two I just got more I
can sleep a little better but nothing
but yet no it is by the by I still feel
those things now even with success sure
I mean that's what I think people don't
understand is that you it really is
everything yeah and when did you know
that you were gonna make that sacrifice
at what point did that happen yes so the
guys and I we did improv and each other
we didn't we met in high school okay
just that that is what makes you show so
great you guys have known each other 30
this year Wow we've met with the same
exact age all born in 76 we met as
freshmen in the same exact school 1990
and and we by the end of it we weren't
even like a clique or anything but we
just were all friendly we just went to a
small school so I knew each other we did
improv in high school we left we all
went separate ways I continued like I
said I did and um I took some acting
classes and then when we all got back
from college in 98 we all were kind of
still doing it a little bit so that
what's interesting is that you all went
to college and then after college it you
guys like you like ran into someone at
the mall let's get the band back
together Peter James at the mall Wow and
he said I started he's like I started an
improv troupe at Georgetown they didn't
have one and actually James James went
to Georgetown with he did improv there
with Birbiglia Kroll and then when he
left Mulaney came in but all those guys
were Jacqueline Novak was yeah oh yeah
oh yeah don't like George challenger's
put out the funniest most successful
those guys like Millay I mean come on
Jesus God even crawled those guys III
admire this story of those guys it's
just a story of how far you can go
coming from poverty you know what I mean
it's just it's so impressive to see very
poor underprivileged people figure it
out
like that's the American dream yeah I
love everyone but yes the Ivy League
schools really put our cross yeah but
those guys are really dumb so funny
because I I i live i their brilliant
Mulaney really big they brilliant
brilliant but yes so he came out of that
little crop and and anyway he was like
oh he's like you want to try do like
improv and stuff and I was like yeah
that's like let's call Joe and then we
called our buddy Mike Q Brian Quinn on
the show he was peripherally around he
was writing and working for Kevin Smith
I think and doing like comic books and
he was writing movies and stuff he was
oh he's very talented he was always
inclined that way and he would join us
at shows and like be a guest on shows
but first it was our buddy Mike and you
guys were the tenderloins yes that's
correct
yeah so my buddy Mike
he kind of left a long time ago started
a family is very successful in his own
right and went a different way and then
somewhere in the middle Chu decided to
join us and then after that was when we
got like was when MySpace and YouTube
started and that's when we transferred
all of the stage stuff we moved on to
sketch comedy right and then we moved on
to filming those sketches and putting
them online so somebody at YouTube and
somebody at myspace saw them would put
them on the homepage and sometimes they
get hundreds of thousands of views in a
couple hours and what had happened was
and I told the store before so I
apologize if people listen and they've
heard this stuff but there was a
competition NBC was having to find a
best sketch comedy troupe and it was
really their way of finding talent on
they were hosting an online competition
they were gonna turn it into a show yeah
but instead of interviewing people they
just held a an online competition for
submissions and every week they gave you
a theme and you had to turn over a
sketch in a week and if you won you
could win a thousand dollars and they
did that for like 20 weeks and hundreds
of sketch troops from all of the country
kept submitting and it was online voting
and out of those twenty weeks we won
like eleven of them
Wow so we won eleven thousand dollars in
twenty weeks filming these sketches with
a handycam and the four of us and they
said were they were they similar to what
you do and practical joker style no
absolutely not they're just pure sketch
comedy actually they still live on
YouTube online some of them hold up some
of them are embarrassed right well it is
what it is you need to crawl before you
can walk
I'm not even sure of course and we will
$11,000 was like literally we won the
Powerball yeah and and then what they
did was at the end of that run it was
gonna be a studio show hosted by Carson
Daly on NBC called like the Battle of
the what-have-yous I don't know and they
took the five best videos they thought
that they found from that whole thing
which by the way that was gonna be their
pilot episode they got content for
$5,000
cuz five videos and then they filmed a
pilot and the audience voted and we won
$100,000 Wow and this was what year this
was 1990
seven so this is a big I was sleeping on
a couch yeah and in a little basement
apartment and we split it and that was
like at the tax it was like 20 grand
each and it was transformative because I
didn't have to worry about like renting
something right and then um the show
never aired to put legally they had to
pay us right so they paid us and from
that we got an agent and then our agent
was at a small boutique agency and later
went to CAA and we migrated with him so
that's how we got a small arrogant to a
bigger agent and then after that we
started writing a pitching TV show how
many shows would you say that you
pitched before Impractical Jokers was
born probably 20 20 shows going into the
pitch meaning how many souls sold 20 no
no no no no yeah pitch 20 maybe sold uh
four so for people that don't understand
you you going to pitch a show when you
sell a show yeah in most cases not
always but you film a pilot yes if
you're lucky
yeah sometimes a good gesture can take a
shorter version of it yeah you film and
I a pilot episode of the show so you did
that a few times yes pilot presentation
about four times for everything from
like we had a show a single-camera
scripted levels like it's always sunny
right that was the first bite we got Fox
and Spike offered to buy it and we were
nervous to go with Fox yeah and we
thought we went with Spike it was a much
smaller boutique thing aimed at guy
sorry just chew you up and spit you out
Fox even offered more money right to
shoot it but well they're they're gonna
they're gonna take a flyer on a hundred
shows and maybe pick two or three right
spike might be doing 1015 shows and
picking two or three right so we went
with spike it was a learning experience
the production company that we did it
with they were a little green to I think
and then the end of it we both learned a
lot it wasn't the best experience now
during this process of pitching shows
and pilots there's everybody a hundred
percent in or do you have to grab one of
you guys one point oh no it's gonna work
out there's like there's somebody is it
because you have that early success you
had that hundred thousand you you won
that contest that there was just this
idea that it was gonna work
well we all
[ __ ] people he also had full-time jobs
oh so nothing's changed nothing's
changing right we were doing those
things everything we've ever done has
been in addition to our full-time job
right so now we have people that can get
us a meeting and so now what now the now
the guys and I are sitting down and
every day having lunch I mean like
what's an idea let's develop another
idea that's because when we go in these
meetings we don't want one idea we want
five ideas right right and we go and
sometimes they fail miserably and now
when we filmed the pilot a pilot
presentation and they only wanted to
gave us like 75 grand spike and they
wanted like five six minutes is Spike TV
still around I have no idea but that was
like television for dudes man and it was
like Robot Wars right as I recall it was
and it was like a digital niche right I
thought maybe we we could succeed there
you know like so so we made it but the
production come there made made it with
decided we're gonna give them the full
30 minutes right because we want them to
see that we could produce this amount of
Tyrael in this amount of time for this
amount of money the fact is we couldn't
do any of that right we spread ourselves
thin we had a loss in quality we had to
put in extra money of our own because it
didn't because we went through their
money right it took longer to deliver
and we didn't give them what they asked
for
right we didn't know any better we just
deferred to them now we know so we were
so salad with that experience that we
left we said we can do this better
a newer idea better by ourselves with no
one else for less money we called in all
favors from friends that we were making
the videos with over the years and
friends that were comics and had talent
we put together a volunteer crew we
chipped in our own money and for $5,000
we made another pilot out there on our
own any con to all these festivals so
that's the lesson is to do it yourself
do yourself that's the lesson the lesson
is if you can do it yourself do it
yourself if you can call in every favor
and do and you will learn more right
because I learned I learned from the
first one but you learn more when you're
making the mistakes yourself too and we
made mistakes too and it didn't and
ultimately that didn't really get picked
up either we almost got a deal with
YouTube at the time but that didn't get
picked up and then we had a couple of
game shows that we shot out they didn't
get picked up and but nobody in the for
view which is
interesting cuz [ __ ] this we're done
nobody everybody now because it was
exciting cuz yeah we went we went in
closer every now is close one yeah is
without an agent now I have one he's
telling us give us ideas so we were
young I mean not we weren't young but it
was we was 30 or no actually no such so
sorry we first started him probably with
20 to 23 by the time this rolled around
we were 30 31 yeah and we were like but
we still felt young I mean we were worse
we had no accomplishments right and and
you know that is still young actually it
is young and you didn't mind living on
the couch and he didn't mind kind of
work the day job and I was getting
little nervous I didn't have health
insurance right I was bartending I was
making really good money bartending yeah
I got into a neighborhood spot and I
really like was good at my job I enjoyed
it and so I was making money to save and
pay all my bills I felt good but it was
off the books with no health insurance I
knew sooner or later something was gonna
give I mean I had a finance degree I you
know I could always go back cuz I left
Prudential and they told me that if I
want to come back I could write and and
I always knew I can go back and then
just as luck would have it after after
we kept failing we said what can be an
idea where we don't have to try to learn
how to do that idea and it's like well
that would just be being ourselves so
what's an idea where we could just be
ourself and then things will hopefully
fall into place and we said well we just
improvise and [ __ ] with each other and
play each other then what do we really
have to learn then we just got to figure
out how to edit it funny and no trust
what we think is funny and that's it we
don't have no camera angles and story
structure and pacing and how to act
better than we did because we didn't
really know how to act right so now
let's not act let's just be ourselves
and then that idea went to true we went
we okay so we had they set us up with
around the pitch meetings before we had
any ideas okay we had the meetings with
it's true and the rest of things
scheduled no idea yet it was a week away
and we sat down thought of it at a lunch
we throw a few ideas that was one of
them and we had the meeting booked
before the idea is the name something
you guys came up with no I hate the name
okay I just I the name is now grown on
me I name is great
I think it I thought it was the word I
was her I was mortified by the name they
they put it on us we went to it and
we're gonna call it a mission
uncomfortable okay because the original
conceit was and we tweaked a little bit
was that we drove around in this van we
pull up outside locations and then
people viewers would send in these
missions for us to do and we'd go in and
compete and see who could do them better
and the van was like it and it was gonna
be voiced by Patrick Stewart and he had
and he didn't like us and he was like an
extra character it was like it went to
alliterations right then we said we got
there where we sitting that [ __ ] the van
you know and [ __ ] submissions let's
write these things ourselves right so he
tweaked it a bit but um what was what
was your where we're going I was saying
the name yeah that's why I was called
mission accountable we thought it fit
well but I will tell you a blessing was
that they named the show what we it was
it now its eponymous it's basically now
what we're called is the name of the
show which is really good to have your
identity tied to the Brent than yes
because I'll bring but when they came
back they were gonna call us Daredevils
and I said I will literally not do the
show right and then they said
Impractical Jokers and I said people are
gonna start calling us the Joker's right
I was like guys I'm a thirtysomething
year-old man I'm trying to take my
comedy seriously like right and who says
the word Impractical its amount 'full
it's an odd word right that people
aren't gonna latch on to also it's corny
yeah a practical joke we're gonna do an
impractical one yeah and I had a feeling
in my gut because all my peers in comedy
because I used to UM run this bar and I
was in comedy already and I hosted a
comedy show every Tuesday night with jf
Aris my buddy he would host it was
called grab-ass it lasted by three or
four years what year was that 2008 eight
nine ten eleven okay and every comic
that you know right now in the city
everyone from Michael che to every
person we know has done that show and I
knew them already as the bartender
manager of this bar that was also in
comedy
before I got in so all my peers I was
like they're gonna hear I got a show and
it's gonna be called Impractical Jokers
and I say
is just demeaning isn't it funny how
that she it's the first reaction you
have is that it's gonna be a demean who
has a video itself has a video of them
telling me he turned the video on and
they told me on the video that the
network is insisting in sis and that's
what it has to be and I had a visceral
nauseated I only lost the blood in my
face I went I turned like a white green
yeah and I literally like was close to
dry heaving he has it on it we cry
laughing when it's off it's the most
successful prank show in history candid
camera okay it's it's getting close
though I appreciate that it's getting
close
I understand historically you have an
argument there but I mean it just or we
don't exist without them but we try to
work multiple genres who's the guy
who's the candid camera guy Allen Funt
Allen Funt correct yeah it was different
it was different but that's the impetus
of everything that came after it yes
that's a great point but we we we don't
even like we don't even call it a prank
show like we don't we don't I mean right
look you get written up and we get
discussed and is it yes it is in an
element of it but when we're making it
we didn't want to fall into that trap I
feel like sometimes you paint yourself
we didn't want to paint ourselves into
being the pranksters and unfortunately a
byproduct of this is that a lot of times
we are and a lot of times people don't
know the show and don't know us and I
meet them I see the judgment because I
think that they don't know what we're
about they haven't given the show a
chance they don't know what I've done
outside of it I've been in the comedy
world I've made a dozen shows I've
written and contributed to a lot of
things I'm a stand-up I'm right I do a
lot of stuff economy but III see even
sometimes one will do like talk shows
right yeah so you guys are the the
pranksters you know it's like look I'm a
I'm a middle-aged man I'm not I'm not
like a YouTube kid turning on my things
slapping somebody in the back of the
head and running like it just they I
feel like it is it's reductive it's sure
but I think when you do it really well
it's an art form I mean it's quite
appreciate that yeah
with the goal you know yeah but but I
thought that the name Impractical Jokers
would would you know perpetuate that
right brand you and and and but now
something happened where it just is what
it is and people over see the name are
you and and honestly it was a blessing
because you the cult we wouldn't be
called the mission uncomfortable now
like so call me a joker
go ahead people people don't do it
anymore with like that's corniest [ __ ]
they just do it like it is what it is
they're the job what is the advice for
people out there that are trying to get
something off the ground that haven't
been able to get it off the ground what
I mean the the it seems you know the
trial and error part of it seems to be
so essential like there's I think I know
certain people I go you're not failing
enough and it sounds wild I think you're
not failing enough I have failed at so
many things I'm still failing at I still
throw things out and I go that wasn't
what I wanted it to be we just fail up
fail up that's the whole move because
there's people out there that are afraid
to try and they're even in the business
of comedy they've you know pushed off
the doctor for you yeah I'm sure right
if you're not you're doing it wrong
right I'm afraid I see comedians I see
young kids I see over my cars with more
confidence than I know that I have I
don't think by the way that's an issue
for them it is because I'm sitting in
your home and they should I'm not saying
that I don't have confidence but I'm
saying I doubt myself routinely I'm
nervous routinely I question if I'm good
enough routinely sometimes I feel good
sometimes I feel bad sometimes I feel
like I belong sometimes they don't
sometimes I feel like I earned and
deserve what I have sometimes I feel
like no one really should earn or
deserve that much for I don't I don't I
I flip flop all the time
but I'll be still in a room and be like
especially I'm trying new stuff or if
there's someone around that I really
respect you know but I see some of these
people walk into a room and god bless
them
because they don't have anything to back
it up per se and I don't mean their
material may be the material sucks maybe
it's okay maybe it's really good but
they're still young and they don't have
a body or they don't have not even warm
perience to back up the feeling but
maybe that's where I'm wrong
cuz maybe they are not mutually
exclusive right if you're that person
that walks around like that every day
and that's who you are then that's who
you got to get out I think sometimes
that can be an asset sometimes it can be
it can really hinder somebody yeah
because the reality is those types of
people go very far or nowhere I've kind
of feel you know because that I've seen
that some of that is genuine some of
that confidence some of that's just
being a sociopath and be like sure I'm
doing I'm a star and here's the thing if
that's where you present yourself and
you position yourself like that
sometimes it works people go oh you're a
star your house it's a fake it till you
make it type things yeah you you if
you're that enough people will be like
oh he's that right then again just get
you could be that keep but sometimes it
doesn't work because what happens is
those people don't have those like dark
nights of the soul where they go man am
i fraud am i even good what am i doing
because I think those are the nights
that make you go okay what do I do
that's going to be funny now like I
transition to doing a lot more stuff on
social media because that was where a
lot of prospective fans were sure and
you know I I was in the development
process and you something similar to
what you described not nearly as many
but like you go through it a few times
and you go I'm watching my career sail
away right because I'm not connecting
with people because I'm working with
suits an industry right and they like me
right they're coming out to shows and
they're going great set and let's make a
show and blah blah blah and that's great
but I'm losing this whole chunk of
people that I need to buy tickets yeah
and really to enjoy what I do because I
want to make people laugh sure and
they're on Instagram and Twitter and
social media and YouTube and that's how
I pivoted to that but again if I if I
maybe was the type of person that was
just like hey well I'm getting meetings
and people like me and to hell with it
I'm gonna you know yeah you know I think
there was part of it of like sitting in
you know my producers garage in Los
Angeles going well what are we gonna do
now you know the pilot is not gonna go
yeah
the scripted show is not gonna go and we
have these tools and maybe we can just
maybe we can be funny and put it out
online and see what happens and then
these dumb little sketches and things we
do you know Joe Rogan's playing them for
Kevin Hart yeah you know people are you
know people like you people that I
respect to go oh these are really funny
things yeah yeah I you know I've
championed you for now you have to tell
anybody we'll listen I can't you write a
book I appreciate your shoes out all the
time no it's it the book is definitely
gonna I'd like to do that that's
something I'd like I'm doing on your bus
tours yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna do maybe
another one of those in the spring it's
so it really is about is it's kind of
like failing out personally now do you
feel you're you're accomplished or
successful you guys have done it is it
ever do you ever get anxiety now because
you're like well what now Oh make no
mistake
I just I'm a person that lives with
anxiety right yeah yeah I mean I think
that every day yeah I I am you know even
when we got the show the show could be
cancelled any moment right we're now
luckily about to start season 9 I think
now the show's not gonna be that the
season 1 you didn't know this issue we
didn't know they held that over us
Rhino you not even their choice what do
people stop watching also we got the
show and didn't know how to make a show
we had the idea we knew we want to do
but then we also have to learn on while
we were doing it how to do it yeah and
now we know how to do it but if I
venture outside of this box I'm gonna
have that process all over again and
this show what while bittersweet will
end soon enough and it'll be a silver
lining because I love the show this is
the golden years I don't know if I'll
ever have something that'll be as big a
legacy as this to me
but I am ready willing and wanting to
explore so many other projects and
creative outlets so that will be the
saving grace when this golden time of
this show passes and I get you know we
lose all the staff that we've become
family another but I'm just looking at
it like alright we'll also like let me
Adam because I want to go and do all
this other stuff
not including stand-up because I got
right now well you know my stand-up is
in every free moment that I have right
but I wanna I wanna you know yeah it's
great problem to have but I want to you
know be online with my peers that are
right putting in you know I want to be
put at full capacity
yeah yeah that's why I won't even do a
special until I could do that so I'm
like waiting until this all ends and I
could dedicate all my time only my time
just to that and then see if I put if I
can put something out that I I'm proud
of and if I and I don't think I can then
I won't write but I but I'm nervous I
don't know like what I'm gonna do after
this and like you know I just I just
know having this there's having money
change cuz there are people that talk
about this is having money change the
the the sense of urgency or the sense of
like you know being being successful
does that cuz some people go I lose my
motivation now no well it's a case the
case I'm sure right and I'll say yes and
no it's gray I know I don't lose
motivation it makes it easier less
stressful to know that I don't have to
worry that I can't pay my rent or
something like that right that peace of
mind is an intangible I mean it's you
can't even but I mean it's that's yes
that helps but I have something that I
want that I haven't achieved yet and I
want to do that because I have a passion
for it not because I'm trying to make
money yeah so that hunger for me is
there and that's the type of person
you've always been because people that
get into this business even though that
they want to make money that they're
their main thing is they want to do
something they like they want to do
something that excites them first of all
anyone getting into comedy or acting or
anything because they like think and it
sounds trite to even say that it sounds
like it's obvious but if you're
listening to this and you want to be an
actor and actress because you want to be
a movie star and you want to be famous
and you want to be rich like you should
not do this you're not going to succeed
right guys no this has nothing to do it
you have no shot I would bet my I would
bet my hard-earned money that you will
never be successful right yeah because
you have to you have to I always check
that this can be the I had to tell you a
story because this is great I mean I had
to tell you a story when you when we go
offline I can't tell it off course that
I wish I could tell online but I don't I
haven't figured out yet how to tell it
where it wouldn't affect people
negatively of course less you will do a
tumble sauce if I tell you off okay well
yeah but anyway
someone's in life need to be pregnant
but yeah but my back my point is is that
like you can't you can't go to the shows
one of the things I like is that when we
see these human the ferryman how
talented are those people yeah I took
Ben to see that show yeah you know those
people are looking guy are not do you
model I should let's not give him a head
looks like freakin a young Brad Pitt
he's fine
the reality is he's got a fashion sense
with those glasses on there's no
six-pack to smile he's got a his hair
flops to the right he's a nice ability
is a nice 5 o'clock shadow 25 years old
25 I wouldn't walk around with somebody
was an Argo yeah you know he's good a
lot of people say that that he's
good-looking and I think it fills his
head but III yeah I'll get you some work
yeah I what get me so been so like the
whole thing is really that these guys
you watch them in the ferry menu like
these are great actors and actresses
some of them are known most of them are
not they're not gonna be known yeah make
some money
maybe they'll but they're doing it
because they love it yes they're
probably happy they're probably happy
yeah yeah and homeless many don't have
homes I can't I I this I promise you
this is real sound will sound syrupy a
little bit every day every [ __ ] day I
can't believe my life and I cannot
believe this happened to me and I'm very
thankful every single [ __ ] day I wake
up I think about it I go to bed I think
about it I don't miss a day I feel that
way I said I can't believe it
like I didn't come from money you know I
came from a good family but not money
and I get to support my entire family
now and I that is there now you're at a
point where you can support
members of your family I'm not saying
I'm not family this is nice but I just
mean like now I feel my feel me doesn't
have to worry us if I worry about money
I don't worry about like my money for me
but I I do worry about money still
because like obviously you I'm I didn't
make money in the beginning even with
the show and now I'm at a place where I
kind of M right yeah and then when that
goes away I I will do other projects and
I'm gonna be comic for the rest of my
life and I'll tour but I might not who
knows is the the level will be at the
level that I'm at after a nine-year
tenure on a project right right who
knows but so I am saving same because I
know that I just want to have peace of
mind that my family won't have to worry
extended family yeah well not have to
worry about anything as long as I'm here
and I did so I have anxiety about that
though the main reason that I've always
wanted to make money is to let my family
know I want to succeed is to let them
know that you have to worry no matter
how I'm doing it has nothing to do with
you you know but I I don't mean to
discourage anyone but it's not a it's
not what you get into something you
don't get into you don't get it stumbles
in it happens you had to love the art
otherwise it's not gonna the lady you
date she's so cool with everything
that's important yeah yeah come easy
yeah that didn't come easy it's a it's a
weird life we live yeah I'm I'm aware
I'm working all day and all night
yeah all day and all night right and
then I'm away you know two three or four
weekends a month sometimes I you know
sometimes I'm not home for a month
sometimes I am not home before you know
3:00 a.m. for a week straight sometimes
I have one not always but sometimes I
have I'll have one day off in a month
right you know like whatever it is like
so so that's an adjustment period but I
think that once you weather it a little
bit and then you know she was able to
see like this isn't like me partying
this isn't me choosing not to be here
this isn't me doing something social
this is me putting all of my efforts and
energy into something I love in order to
succeed
to help us right you know and once you
see that it's just like okay and then
then you get on that team and then she
helps me because like I you need a sub
if you're in a relationship you need the
full support of that person and I will
tell you wrinkles on my wall right there
I got to meet Rickles before he passed
yeah and I talked to him for a while and
that was one of the first things I met
him what my dad and she was there and he
sat down he talked about cuz he's
married till the end he married when he
passed to his wife and he said that that
was the most important thing to him was
to have someone that was his backbone
that understood what he was doing
supported it didn't question it and only
enabled it and helped it you know
despite all the regular bumps that yeah
no [ __ ] and I believe that I believe
that cuz it's gonna it's gotta be hard
because you you don't want any any uh
any barriers to entry of what you're
trying to do and it's a person that you
that you're involved with isn't getting
it how many people that are pursuing
something creative let's be honest their
partner's not into it and they pretend
to be into it
most people are just not into it I think
it's specifically in a in a place where
one person has an unconventional career
right you know I'm everyone if you both
do in separate nine-to-five so oh you
have a job or whatever it is if it's
something but when it's something this
unconventional the other person has to
and then by the way with success comes
you know more challenges because like
who the hell wants to be like your
pictures put up people say mean things
about you and force walk around people
yeah have an opinion it's just not a you
just sacrifice privacy that's a good
thing too yeah and and no privacy is
tough in for relationship to so there
are like these little things that you
never really think about but then they
present themselves do you have to
navigate them I wouldn't change anything
for the world of course if you want a
little insight as to like that kind of
feeling yeah there's always a set of
challenges what do you love about Staten
Island because I love Staten Island
because I wouldn't think well when I ya
Ivan history with Staten Island when I
first started stand-up comedy I was
selling copiers telemarketing copiers in
Tottenville at a place called reliable
office systems and is just the best name
ever
yeah reliable office systems we're
reliable that was that was it
that was the hook and I would take a
ferry I was living in midtown Manhattan
with Jan lures by the way I'm Jesse
Dodge
I was literally not I didn't know that
was living with that in the spare room
of their apartment it was it was the
second Forester watched it was crazy
first one was my parents second one was
damn I bear responsibility I think a
little bit for both I reverse commuted
that's when I reverse commuted which is
and I had a whole joke about a whole bit
about it where I was like we're going to
pass a statue Liberty but we're going
the wrong way and it was crazy and I
would I would take a train to the Staten
Island Ferry and then I would get on the
ferry get off the ferry and by the way
get on the S 74 bus yeah the Tottenville
which is another hour that's before our
the commute was a two-hour process to
get to reliable office systems I'll get
up at 6:30 I get to my desk by 9:00 I'd
worked to 1 or 2 I'd get back into the
city by 4:00 or 4:30 and then do open
mic and you had to because that's where
the work was that's why would
immediately be like where can I do this
where I am well then they eventually
after a few months of that they moved me
to their office on 6th Avenue and made
me like a copier guy and then I was like
the problem was I was getting dragged
into the nine-to-five world where they
were like oh you're gonna wear suits and
you're gonna be this is why every
bartender and then I had to stay so
eventually while I was walking home I
saw one of the tour buses and I went oh
that seems so free to just stand on that
bus and talk and nobody cares that's
what I have to do I can't beat an office
all day because then you start to go out
to work dinners and everything and you
start to get sucked into that vortex
yeah you saw a bus pass and the light
bulb went off light bulb went off and I
said I should do that while I wanted
while I learn what I need to learn and
while I you know can't make money a
comedy I shouldn't be in an office but
the time I was in Staten Island maybe
three months four months intense tatting
on him he sat on an everyday dinner and
Angelina's a lot quarterly dinners might
like I'm a lovin Island Christmas
parties I I really for whatever so this
is your sister he's very similar very
similar
everybody's Italian everybody's kind of
in the mob
they're in the mob yeah yes your opening
sale for sure yeah hunger scholar it's
it's it's more conservative right it's
old-school
it's it's just like any other place I
like to say cuz I know Staten Island
there's a stigma with it and it does get
a bad rap and not not for no reason cuz
taro type disease is for a reason one of
my jobs you know it's a with the worst
place in the cities you have to take a
boat to get there and it's free that was
my job 30 minute boat ride the city's
like this is on us that's great yeah
bull rides the best charming as [ __ ] get
at all boys sit outside see the statue
go back and forth this spring and summer
there's nothing better um I love it here
because this is the this is what made me
who I am
right simple as that that's what I like
Who I am I take the good with the bad
here I get what people don't like
certain things I just don't like when
people trash it just like I was saying
at the top of our conversation like even
about like our show or just like I don't
like when people judge right and I and
and look I I just don't like when people
if people are educated and can trash it
but then also good tell me the good
things they like about it right I didn't
give me a well-balanced take on it
that's no problem 100% people are just
like [ __ ] these people [ __ ] oh you're
from there oh you're automatically this
which I get all the time my name is Sam
yeah I'm Staten Island you know I do a
prank quote-unquote show which I [ __ ]
hate I don't use the word prank in the
office right we don't have to say it
interesting it's it's a hidden camera
show okay and and and it's about friends
right that's what it is right and we
write the [ __ ] out of that show right
improvise but we write they [ __ ] out of
headquarters well not a lot this is
because it's non-union so it's like so
it's like they could put it in under the
geyser like they put it in a reality
show right so people call when we can do
interviews they call it a prank show
which we don't think it is and a reality
show which we don't think it is a
reality when you think of reality show
you think of you know car - you know
whatever they matter work that goes into
your show - yeah yeah just you know
contrived people looking for you know
it's a contrived it's produced and it
it's you know they're looking for these
sound bites in
right your flair right to have you know
nuggets to put online to get viral it is
what it is in it and these people don't
like that and I've watched reality shows
but we're not that so you know it is
what it is but um what was I so yeah but
if you judge the island then you don't
know much about it I I don't I don't
like that cuz this the some of the best
most salt of the earth wonderful people
that I've met here some of my lifelong
friends here my family's here you know
good good people yeah of course so just
like anything else is some [ __ ] there's
some [ __ ] but it's nice it's nice and
it's a stone's throw from the island but
you get like a bit of the suburbs here
like have you ever so you've taken the
train I don't know how much you've
actually traversed I've taken the train
up and down Staten Island so you know
the train cars here take you through
like some places and you wouldn't even
know you were in style oh it's beautiful
isin the suburbs and it's gorgeous yeah
there's there's a lot of history here
which people don't know about
yeah for sure for you know I love it
here because there's a lot of character
here and I like character one of my
complaints about Manhattan is everything
so corporate now that you the character
is unfortunately has been lessened by
that you don't have as many mom-and-pop
stores or little diners or restaurants
and the people that would hang out in
those places yeah and the people that
would own those places you're much more
likely to find in Queens or Brooklyn or
Staten Island oh they're all over this
yeah so those are the characters that to
me make New York fine and the
neighborhood the people in your
neighborhood and the you know you now
the people in your neighborhood is like
chase you know $300 a head sushi place
you know and it's like okay that's not
what I think of when I think about New
York the friendships with the guys they
all have they changed over the last
thirty years is it still the same this
is pretty much the same wild I mean
we're closer than we ever were because
we have to be with each other
legitimately all the time 24 [ __ ] 7
so is another rule when you pick people
to collaborate with pick people that you
can spend time with and people that you
can oh boy yeah yeah yeah and I think
that we do a good job at that despite
even our own disagreements arguments
everyone occasional blowouts to set the
other we got us and we are for not even
to we we have to it's a democracy a lot
of times
but we trust each other and a lot of
times we'll if someone is so there are
arguments yeah if there are well yeah oh
they're not too many arguments there are
yeah but um but when it comes to the
creative part of it it's we're pretty
good we're pretty good we'll convince
each other if we think an idea is good
and someone doesn't or we'll give it a
whirl and if it doesn't work we'll learn
from the mistake but it's not so much
the creative part as much as is the
business side too like we have them we
have collectively probably sometimes
anywhere from one no joke to 100
decisions to make a day as a team right
so we have learned how to do that but
every once in a while it's still like oh
we hit a stalemate you know but it's no
small feat to be like sometimes just be
asked like 50 questions there's a lot of
people I think that aren't for whatever
reason aren't ready to take the next
step or they're not ready to be
successful or they're not ready to have
any Mallick what do you think the
challenges are people don't really
understand like there's a lot of people
that constantly get in their own way and
that's either subconsciously maybe fear
of success fear of failure
whatever it is self sabotage now what do
you think separates people that are
willing to take the next step or ready
really ready because a lot of people are
willing they're just not ready how do
you what makes people ready to make a
hundred decisions today sure if they
need to that's a big thing I don't think
anyone is ready right um and I don't
think if you think you're ready you're
probably not it's just about a a knowing
that you have to be ready whether you
like it or not and then do the best you
can I would I wasn't ready for there's
no one's ready for it but I think a big
help is to like you said have a lot of
failures I got I got this kind of
success relatively late in my life yeah
so we got two shows I know a lot of
YouTube kids in LA and they're 23 and
they have millions of dollars that's I
think look God blessed them right good
luck with them and I wish I'm the best I
hope they manage the money and I hope
they manage their day-to-day and their
relationships the right way and they get
out on the other end of that because
if it's also the way you were raised I
think and I think that younger people
now and I could be completely wrong and
I think everything's cyclical and I
think people probably said this about us
and people said this about our parents
and the rock music and the rap man all
that [ __ ] whatever it is but I think I
think especially now kids are being
raised with the Internet which i think
is different than television in the fact
that people's opinions ideas the world
is very six accessible around them
they're saturated with information about
everything opinions about everything and
and I think that success now is equated
with you know likes friends retweets and
so people are chasing Klout now as a kid
I think cloud is important to young kids
now in a way that it wasn't before cloud
in high school maybe right was my thing
of that cloud in the neighborhood you
know not clout globally right and so
when kids now are they're square one is
like how do I get global clout right
that is a very right that's right that's
a great point like how can I be a global
phenomenon before how can I clear these
out the priorities I never learned
does it ever worry you I look at some
you know I look at comedy and where it
is right now and there's so much and I
understand it I have to do it myself
there's so much of an emphasis on
marketing getting yourself out there
it's like comics from learning how to
you know they're selling t-shirts before
they have an act I mean everything is
like it doesn't ever worry you about
just the future of like art in general
the idea that everything is so
fast-paced and that you need to really
learn and and the emphasis and the focus
seems to be on just getting so much
stuff out there forget whether it's good
or not forget whether it's you know
valuable or not just putting stuff out
there and everybody's got to see
themselves as like you know everybody's
got to be like a marketing company and
does it ever do you ever wonder like you
know where that leads does that lead to
just kind of very
sheep are eventually I think well an
argument you mean from every side as art
is so subjective right like that [ __ ]
guy that that they near the banana to
the wall last week and he [ __ ] ate it
and like what glares that yeah what the
fry and that's old people so they're
fried up to right i still selling
bananas both quarter million right but i
think that someone could it could be
said that look ever art begets art and
this is all art and take it or leave it
and so you know it's whatever someone is
into is valid i don't i think it's a
dangerous thing yeah because i think
that like i just said that is the trend
from square one so we already have
saturation in the form of how we can
access his information
now this saturation in the amount of
people that are trying to do it as well
right it's just it's expounds it's just
it's to the point where when we first
started doing the YouTube stuff and
someone put us on we got a few hundred
thousand views we were like whoa
and then the myspace blew up and then
they were ranking comedians and then it
felt like this gold rush right right
this type of thing which is now having a
revolution still going there's a
renaissance of the like but I would say
oh [ __ ] like everyone's doing it now so
like now how are we gonna keep up and I
remember having this conversation with a
friend of mine he's like look like
anything else people will rush to it and
then a lot of output will be made and
then that the best stuff will rise to
the top and you know and you'll see like
you know if it's good it's good and that
should be the great the great equalizer
the people will find the good stuff and
the trash will fall by the wayside and
those people will give up and you'll you
will get good content from it
I believed that at the time now I think
we've have a somewhat of an epidemic
because now I think that we are so
saturated and then flooded with content
that it's the new normal and people
cannot even find the good content or at
least it's harder to and all of these
kids now are accepting and I mean this
even and I'm not calling anyone
specifically I they're a very talented
internet people of Corey counted
SoundCloud people interested there also
is so much [ __ ] just like anything else
and I think that there's so much [ __ ]
available that the masses of young
people are now just
accepting the [ __ ] as the baseline good
right and they're redefining what is
acceptable as quality yeah and they are
outnumbering us we're dying yeah
they're not there of the perfect spent
twenty years to get to where they're
going and and I'm only 43 I'm not like
I'm an old man no of course I'm
traditional kind of being supplanted and
replaced by people like you said that
are just kind of like this even the
people that are putting great content up
on the internet right now are outweighed
by 1 billion teens that are just like
Johnny on the camera right jump cutting
themselves twirling their hair right
blowing bubblegum
slapping their friend in the face with a
piece of ham or saying I write this nail
polish or whatever it's and now these
people are getting 10 billion views yeah
and they cannot be denied by
corporations so they have to give them
money because they need views on
anything and we are changing the
landscape we're lowering the bar we are
no and I think that even someone who's
honest with themselves even someone
who's gotten success from that medium
should be able to say well hopefully you
know I got success but this people this
frauds out there that our successful
have no right to be we all know that
before again that's happened in every
iteration like even when we were younger
people fall into success that shouldn't
be there I suppose but but I just think
it's bad because because this is about
hive mind now that oh this is what this
is what is entertaining this is what is
quality this is what should be inspiring
me this is what I'm taking my cues from
right yeah I mean yeah so I don't you
cared because I like just I don't have
it in me to be the guy that's always
turning on some of our friends are
really good at it like um Bert Kreischer
amazing at it Chris Edie amazing at it
like they're just really good they turn
on the camera they could say whatever
they want you you're great at it yeah
you know and but but I don't have the
inclination and maybe and maybe it's
because I I just I spread myself a
little
and so when it comes to like put this up
promote this say so I'm funny well let
him into my kitchen and see what I'm
doing over here or you know give him
today's quip or whatever I just I just
don't have I just don't have the I don't
have the motivation to do it and I know
that it's to my own detriment like I do
it but I do it like very half-assed I'm
not gonna do all the I haven't done the
snapchat I'm not gonna do the tick-tock
I'm not going to do any last thing I
don't even do I even have issues with
instagrams stories right you know I'll
do the Instagram post yeah but luckily I
got a little success right now I don't
have to like lean on a hard but alive
ticket sales it's everything is it sad
when you see comics in their mid-forties
and their truth they just have to do
this stuff I don't think it's sad I
think as long as they do it well right
then they utilize it was like its help
sometimes you see like older Long Island
comics who are like my daughter told me
about the use exactly they're out of its
Alvin I really appreciate you talking he
had way more of a I'm in you know I
didn't give you I don't know if we had
any go Falls I wanted to know it's
[ __ ] it up but I you know I also want
to need to know they're gonna fail and
that's what my shows funny enough you
got archives it's very popular people
can laugh but every now and then we need
to do an episode telling people that
they are going to fail you're gonna fail
and that's the thing if people need to
know that and I mean people pay
attention the people are the people that
know someone that's gonna fail tell them
tell them you're not being a friend yes
you're not being a friend to them tell
them they're gonna tell them listen to
me I love you maybe this isn't for you
this isn't for you at least keep it in
mind yes I feel like I you might hate me
but one day if you mature enough you
will know that I did you a service the
people around the people that are going
to fail tell them and by the way if you
persevere past that and you succeed good
you were meant to succeed right and and
and
and you needed that to succeed right but
the people that aren't gonna succeed
just try to be a little more self-aware
two main lessons from the show are you
personally you're going to fail and you
should also tell others that they are
going to fail that's true you can
encourage them you can encourage him
saying you know what listen listen you
could do a lot of things nobody that's
the other thing sometimes you know there
was there was a friend of mine who
wasn't doing a lot of stand-up and their
friend said something about like oh you
should do more stand-up or you're
hanging out with this person they don't
do you know they're not pushing you to
do standard but here's the thing with
everything people do what they want they
do what they're good at and no one can
tell anyone what to do this is the thing
that nobody will realize nobody could
this is my problem with a lot of these
online motivational speakers and things
like that it's all great I'm glad it
pumps yob it makes you feel good it's
really entertainment more than anything
else because a lot of people are gonna
go to where they're gonna go they might
take a weird route to it yeah they might
take a straight route to it they might
go well you know some of them might not
get there but they're gonna end up where
they're kind of gonna end up so this
whole collective identity and idea of
like all you know worrying about what
other people are doing or worrying about
other people influencing you like there
are no influences there are influences
creatively they're anything but you're
either gonna do it or you're not
look.this also let me look there's also
people that are naturally funny and
that's something you can't teach right
there are people that are not
necessarily naturally funny but work
hard learn how to tell and write jokes
and become great at it excel at it that
I probably even famous right now right
I'm not saying to you that if you've
tried for five years and haven't made it
you're gonna fail and you suck I'm not
saying that at all I'm saying that I'm
saying that just be self-aware yes like
make goals short and long-term see if
you're making progress see if you be
honest with yourself is all I'm saying
because if you're half-assing it and and
you're not then you're wasting
everyone's time right I'm just saying
like even if you have to be the friend
to be like look I want you to see it I
wanted to keep trying I think you're
funny I think you do have talent but I
the way that you're approaching it I
don't see something happening for you
and look if your
strong enough of a person and you're
talented if enough of a person that's
not gonna matter but I just don't want
to see someone who's trying a year two
three four five ten and we gotta look
down deep and go why am I really do you
need a plan everyone said that just get
on stage yeah get on stage just get on
stage that's the first thing yeah but
also you need a [ __ ] plan yes don't
you can't just be like people tell me
I'm funny or I like doctor I want to be
bad you need a plan every day follow the
plan
take notes see if you're making any
progress you know you have to do that
and I I don't know I just don't want to
be like you know but motor will always
get at least most people are not funny
strictly talking comedy it's hard to
make a career out of being funny yeah it
is a very difficult thing it can be done
it is done a lot of people will do it
but it's tough it is not easy and you
got to have a plan and you got to be
willing to do everything you gotta like
drop all your preconceived notion
yourself with people that are positive
and good at what they do and that you
can learn from but not in a way to like
these young comics that just become like
Ryan incessant in-your-face to the point
where like I get that you're hungry and
I get that you're trying to make
opportunity right but you also have to
remember that there's a human element to
it and you cannot go savagery
just be make natural friendships organic
natural friendships put yourself in a
place if your people do that to you
where they're just crazy yes
yeah and that's I get it I get it I get
hey you think I could help you right you
even it whether it's like some people
all like can you just get me work or
Julie put me on a show get make a show
for me let me be on your show I was at
the cellar the other day a guy hits me I
won't name names I will after we hang up
do we hang up the phone here that one is
he had some egos hey how you doing I
said good he goes you're that guy if
you're that guy from the show the
printables this is what he called it
like he literally Mutual's
he goes you're on a prank couples you're
on HBO I said yeah he goes what you name
ed I might yeah
what's the name of your show now I got
to tell him in practice that's it
huge fan watch it all the time can I get
on a show I love it how so
like I'm really funny everyone knows
IIIi play here I play here he says I'm a
teller he could like play here yeah he
goes so uh can I get on the show I said
well the show don't really work that way
you know it's the four of us were 30
years old right yeah no problem but here
here's my youtube here's my card look me
up and then he goes you got it you got a
pen and I was like no I guess this is my
youtube but my Instagram is this but
with an underscore and my other one is
this whether that look me up tonight
leave me a message let me know rut a
mail me this is my email I'm not kidding
with it Wow who was saying what Vito was
sitting with me yeah he was all right my
name is this III I work here I'm good
yeah I mean I just keep you know and I'm
sometimes people will break into the
[ __ ] green room and be like I just
can I get on your show can you get can
you give me a show Wow so that don't do
that but go go to where the people are
that you want to be hang out make
natural friendships let people like you
for who you are and then stick with
those people stick with like-minded
people especially if you want to be a
comedian yeah go to the clubs plant your
ass there right observe work talk do it
it might take a long time to do it make
those friendships then you got to get
around like-minded people you got to you
can't be an island alone trying to do
something you have to change your
lifestyle to where everyone else around
you is thinking the way that you're
thinking I think that's a good
accelerator and I would also say have
like when you said have a plan is so
important but also have an idea of what
you want to do and who would out there
would enjoy it like yeah cuz talking to
who is this for Musa for who is it for
by the way I speak like I'm I'm talking
like I'm Jerry Seinfeld over here yeah
I'm I'm still young in comedy I got
lucky I still have all my doubts I I
don't do everything right I'm not
speaking like some I'm giving you my
experience in opinion not speaking like
I'm the law on this right
still learn every single day and I'm
still afraid to fail and I question all
that stuff too but I at least I will say
that I know that I'm self aware of yeah
you know I mean so just be that at least
you know yeah yeah be that folks be self
aware I like its opening I'm talking I
know doling out advice like I'm this
like so yeah your shows in the history
of television not mistake this for me
doling out from my [ __ ] the people
need to be the water the people that are
listening to this that this might apply
to need to have their oxygen card you
were more successful than anyone at the
cellar I needed the cellar there
whatever they want to do mothers like
Seinfeld and a few of them it's really
it's the reality I don't mean mommy
there's a lot of people there that are
eating pigeons in the park and then
having really good SATs but let's get
real about let's get real they're gonna
die people will find salad Sal Vulcano
and a practical jokers you know where I
actually please I'm about to announce my
2020 theater tour for myself soon on Sal
Vulcano comedy calm and the guys and I
just announced a 40-something city tour
of all next summer and we we got because
I want your audience to know about this
stuff too who knows if we share him of
course and then the new show misery and
next on TBS got picked up for season 2
my comedy is very family friend we got a
tree should have talked about that
because I also try to have you with me
when I can here and there did a cruise
and it was you're [ __ ] fantastic it
was hysterical also hysterical which we
didn't touch on the the I think it was a
history hyenas you did
so funny we have not so on next time
100% yeah so just the tour Sal Vulcano
comedy calm and what the [ __ ] else was
it oh the movie our movie comes out
practical jokers fell February 21st
fairy gun jokes get it get it get it
Tim villain comedy calm all that crap
Tim dude don't let Instagram Twitter
thank you rate review subscribe you're
gonna fail thank you